in golf when it comes to diversity it
has been honestly a tough road
I wanted to put down on paper what I
wanted to look like while I was on a
golf course you know jeans sweatshirt
Cuban link chain and some sneakers and
even a fitted hat and we're literally
gravitating people to the game just
through clothing
my name is olajuwana janaku founder of
Eastside Golf and also professional
golfer and I'm Earl Cooper co-founder
and also one of the best young teachers
in America
a lot of other golf Brands you'll see a
golf slash Leisure wear where hours is
golf slash streetwear a lot of times
people see our logo and we've been told
they see themselves taking the club back
chain and Swinging one way you know it
represents that I belong it represents
something I felt golf has been missing
for a long time
and now we're growing into a brand that
is truly changing golf
we have a wide range of consumers that
you know go from an age range of 70
years old down to 17 years old men and
women and we feel like that's just
representative of what the game really
should be and look like and a lot of the
pieces actually live on and off the golf
course like we have boutiques that are
interested in the polos but then also
you know Pro Shops we're rooted in golf
we are a golf brand but we also aren't
lost in the fact that there is so many
other people out here that don't know
the game it's designed from a
perspective of it's a dual use it truly
is very important to see representation
in the game when you look at golf itself
they sell two golfers when we're coming
in I mean we have the Partnerships with
NBA and MLB I mean we're talking to
these other organizations that truly
want to see golf expand
I would say one of the challenges that
we've had you know since we don't have
an apparel background just as far as the
production process you know that's
something that we had to learn being an
entrepreneur I don't think people truly
recognize the fact of how difficult it
is especially if you're starting in the
space where it's never been done before
it's not just a business that we are
just doing to do we're passionate and we
deeply care about it so there's a
process that you know we have to
maintain as well and so be in it for the
long haul we are hiring right now we're
looking to scale the business and
doubling staff by the end of the year I
feel like it's going to make the world
of difference and move our company
forward
one of my favorite moments honestly when
I designed our first Jordan our Jordan
Retro 4 it was really hitting off of the
colors that I put on the logo itself you
know Navy gold gray and white but then
also putting a canvas on the bottom it
was just a fantastic experience
I think also signing our first athlete
Wyatt Worthington and the moments that
we've been able to give back to
Morehouse College you know our alma
mater being able to go back and doing a
collab with beach by Dre and these are
just moments that for us we dreamed of
[Music]
as we look down the road with each side
golf what excites me the most is one of
the opportunities that we'll be able to
offer folks you know when it comes to
working for a young fresh company and
that are doing real changes also excited
to you know new collaborations partners
that we'll be working with we're
actually going to be now accessible on
video games PGA 2K 23 and NBA 2k23 it's
going to make our brand just go so much
more further you know and and reach such
a younger demographic
we're not here to make you know
professional golfers we're here to
introduce you to the game so you can use
this game as a tool because with
whatever you want to do in your life
this game of golf can help you with that
for me my own personal experience I
wasn't always comfortable on the golf
course it wasn't something that I
immediately loved but once I saw the
opportunities that were out there I was
like Wow and so that young kid that's
watching this trust and believe that
golf can offer you all the things that
you may see in other sports whether it
be basketball or football or baseball
you may just not know that they exist
but they definitely do
foreign
[Music]